on peut savoir ce que tu fais
les enfants me poser des questions sur
la famille de
[Musique]
mirabel n'en a aucun
c'est vrai tu n'as aucun pouvoir réel
les maisons est libre et sa spéciale
pour la salle des mariages qui n'a aucun
d'eau c'est donc une livraison spéciale
qui n'a rien de spécial parce qu'elles
n'ont aucun pouvoir c'est gentil
j'oubliais antonio du coup de chance la
dernière cérémonie c'était une vraie
catastrophe est forcément la décrire ce
que la tienne et ça n'a pas marché si
j'étais toi je serais vraiment très très
triste écoute moi bien jeune fille je ne
suis pas triste parce que la vérité
c'est qu'avec ou sans pouvoir je me sens
aussi exceptionnel qu'il restait de ma
famille
va déjà pouvoir ce ne serait pas de nier
la réalité
[Musique]